[Music]
you got your prospective happy don't you
want to be happy I here's how I think we
should do it I think you guys should be
sending me clips and if you don't get an
answer like I think you do it twice like
kind of what you just did and I think
tonight you kind of go with the third
and final chance otherwise we're done a
title five is the right way to do it
got it yeah I thought so too
okay turn me realize the Machine halfway
not
yeah it's really incredible and I'm
seriously going away right yeah I mean
you know when you purposely the sky's
something it's hard for anybody to know
[Music]
that going from 2 to 15 it's like going
from 50 to 100 it's easier the problem
is people go from 2 to 50 and then they
change everything because they think
they've made it or they've figured it
out or they they go from humility to ego
their behavior changes and the reason
fifty to a hundred is equally as hard is
it becomes a mental game based on the
predicated success of the past and I
think staying in those tried and true
being disproportionately bringing value
to the end consumer hiring the great
people what I get excited about when I
hear you talk is understanding now how
to go all-in and and how to be great at
LinkedIn marketing not just do it right
you know I always think about that I
think about like a kid who has an uncle
who comes and visits and then all of a
sudden puts them on skis and they love
it and they're like oh this is good but
then they have to put in the work and
that's why they become an Olympic skier
it did take the uncle to show them but
then it took them to put in the work in
the practice to get some ridiculous
results from it
it's d-roc dear Harriet just joined
Vayner for to lead all comms for the
bean or ex world
Zack is the CEO of [ __ ] speakers
cheese situation is proper no but it is
super property as a nice Jew as a nice
Russian Jewish boy like T is like
culture of course that's like the one
thing mean all my UK friends like like
when I first started going to London a
bunch like that was the one thing that I
like resonated with so well this is
gorgeous I don't want to know the
questions I don't know I feel like we
should be I feel I feel like we should
go live on Instagram and I literally
have a phone because I think we should
do call people and just make their day
like we have all this time I'm like
literally stressed by having this much
time before we go on yeah like we should
make like we should call people randomly
like that's literally what I'm thinking
well you do what you need to do it
[Laughter]
well there's just too much downtime so I
was gonna be content like butter good
ready
[Music]
so many people were asking me like how
how do I live my dream Gary and you know
I don't have time I have mortgages and
bills and responsibilities in my job I
don't have time for my side hustle my
twitch channel my Instagram account my
Shopify stores selling pretties and I
keep getting to this new place which is
talk to me about your bills like why'd
you buy an apartment that stretches you
why is your car so fancy like why do you
need the new Gucci every time like why
are you why are you going out Thursday
Friday and Saturday night like why are
you going to Coachella like why why are
you going to a vendors opening night and
buying the biggest piece of popcorn and
candy like the answer to all of your
questions is not how much money you make
or how much time you have it's what
you're spending your money on we can do
a lot more of this which is what we used
to do like that's like a good piece of
content there may not be anything more
human than tinder yet we demonize it in
reverse because it is not the current
social accepted like like I really
believe like like I hate when people
like judge feeling like what are you
supposed to do with your chemicals in
your 20s that's exactly like the most
like actual true you know what I mean
we've evolved so much that is how we
look at it but like you know what it's
on your time to control when you're
engaging versus I'm gonna step aside
three hours and go to the bar in 1987
and see what happens
versus the collective the three and a
half week ghosting conversation is still
one tensive amount of time that going
out on that Friday you know what I mean
like it's like you're in control your
time like you're in between subway stops
and now you've decided to hit up that
conversation first like I don't know I
feel like look technology exposes things
it doesn't change things and so like I
don't know I sit on the others
[Music]
yes now online datings the greatest one
has ever happen to people and like
they're in control of it like you don't
like it don't usually like I love people
that even eyes online dating but then
like [ __ ] on people writing letters
right like like pick a side
[Music]
I got that super excited about it huh
super super excited about it once it
gets like two or three thousand you
could tell them what I'm about to do all
right so I'm tasting this and then we're
going to a meeting somebody's will bang
this out like yeah okay good excited
Instagram big news this is the first
time I'm trying the empathy wines white
which will start delivering starting
Thursdays Nate
the handsome partner trout you're
supposed to say the grains or something
yeah no bottle shock no bottle shock we
should be shipping third or fourth with
them week of May so three to four weeks
well I mean do you think somebody might
sneak it for Memorial Day that's cool
but right nope without over-promising
fourth of July is gonna be lit by the
way if you're not reordering your
rosette you're making a huge mistake
you can order rose' in three six nine
three six twelve by itself right now if
you go to empty whines I know bunch of
you've gone through your rose' already
so go do that if you order three it's 27
bucks if you order a case it's 20 bucks
something we need to communicate to some
peeps how big all right here it is just
warming it up a little bit more no I
know yeah like thank God no that is the
one difference between the book and the
sneakers and the wine is the real
ordering first of all a lot of people
didn't believe it was gonna be good so
everybody got their three rows A's and
like I mean the amount of people that
hit me up that said I bought it to
support you know I was gonna give it
away and then me or my wife or my me or
my husband or whoever like we tried it
and we'd like it now we just ordered it
so you focus on why are you might be
like this it's a good situation okay
here we go the white aromatics are
killer we're gonna win that game what's
the final breakdown a Bridals you know
that means you do know so Shannon and
Grenache Blanc are two of the three most
highest percentages watch it how much
Chenin love it
guys I made this wine like we we made
this wine with you no actually actually
I can't say we cuz I can't speak to what
these guys were thinking for me
selfishly when we were tasting I was
like you know we need to make out a wine
that just changes the white wine game
cuz rose' in red or eating up the gate
like Reds have been established froze
days eating into white we got to get
people excited about white again and I
don't think that can just be something a
Blanc I don't think that just can be
Chardonnay
I think it needs to be a blend and when
I think of Grenache
and I think of Chenin Blanc but I think
of Chardonnay foundational in the middle
like I'm excited all right what else
[Applause]
here we go
aromatics our lady
[Music]
[Music]